allez un peu de sport à présent avec une
défaite du TVB en Ligue des Champions
une défaite malgré un jeu encourageant
le tour volleyball s'est incliné hier
soir 37 à1 face aux Italiens champion au
titre de Trentino la victoire logique de
l'une des équipes favorites de la
compétition aura quand même permis au
tour en jou de montrer un bon visage de
quoi donner espoir aux supporters de
Grenon pour la suite de la saison Lesa
turquy une défaite oui mais la tête
haute le tour volleyball s'incline face
à Trentino 37 à1 à l'issue d' un match
acharné difficile de réitérer l'exploit
de la victoire contre le club polonais
réchaud la semaine passée ce mercredi
soir à Grenon le TVB s'est battu non
sans mal face au champion d'Italie en
titre ce soir on a tombé dans un équipe
championitalie c'est pas par hasard mais
quand même on a montré un en certains
moment un beauon niveau en certains
moment on a tombé dans dans les fautes
qui normalement on fait pas on joue
contre Trento comme équipe comme comme
ils sont tr point pour eux c'est c'est
c'est rien la soirée commence avec un
premier set très compliqué des erreurs
et des Italiens qui ne laissent rien
passer 1725 pour Trentino 2e set le TVB
sort la tête de l'eau et garde
l'ascendant jusqu'à 1916 avantage
finalement renversé par une attaque de
l'Avia et la machine italienne redémarre
puis conclu 2225 au 3è acte Grenon
assiste à une montée en puissance des
tourangeau qui arrache le set 2523 après
une longue bataille de quoi aller
titiller l'un des clubs favoris de la
compétition chose qui n'est pas donné à
tout le monde on les a fait douter
pendant un 7 demi voire de set dommage
qu'on a pris une série au milieu de ces
4e set sinon on pouvait même envisager
une possibilité de Tae break mais bon
voilà la Ligue des Champions c'est pas
l'objective primaire on prend beaucoup
de plaisir et on on est très content de
partager beaucoup de lutt et beaucoup de
de de la bonne bagarre on va dire
maintenant retour à l'objectif premier
pour le Tour volleyball le championnat
de France prochain match samedi soir à
domicile contre
[Applaudissements]
Narbon